foreign
I'm very excited I'm very excited to
have this guest it's it's stand-up
comedian and he was in a [__] cult
which is [__] odd like those two
things are amazing stand-up comedy I
know no I've seen those guys they're
[__] just know like I said they're
Uber drivers this is hi uh we well we're
well we're gonna look what you [__] up
my intro hi Davey Jackson welcome aboard
thank you for being here we appreciate
it stand-up comedy is a cult it really
truly is it really is no doubt about it
in my mind yeah we thought we'd have
yawn you could talk about the craft and
talk about that talk about how you know
you're different than all these
civilians right yeah yeah that's yeah
you know what you want to do I've
learned this in comedy you like talking
down to people you know you let them
know that like your mind you have a
creative mind and it works differently
than other peoples
yeah well I mean I do like talking down
to other people but mostly I just like
talking down to myself because I grew up
in a cult and was you know just broken
traumatized I'm a mess can I tell you
why his guidance counselor was like you
were in a cult you should do stand-up
comedy probably you're not you know what
I mean I have a guidance counselor I was
homeschooled and in a cult oh yeah this
is okay look this is [__] wild
because I messaged you I went through I
thought I was going to watch a bit I
went through the whole thing I watched
before I [__] been to the whole
[__] show
holy [__] bro what the [__] okay so for
those who don't know all right
so remember that show whatever 50
billion and Counting whatever that
Duggar family show and it was it was on
TLC all the time I remember I remember
my mom watching it right and it was it
was on all the time and it was about
this this family who they were super
Christian and they just had a bunch of
kids and like every year the mom would
have like two more kids I don't know how
and it was just like 19 kids at one
point
um and and she by the way is medically
not recommended like when you have a kid
you're supposed to you know recharge the
batteries give the system a little time
to build back up so it's these guys for
I'm sure you guys I'm sure everybody
knows it's like this is one of the
biggest this is one of the biggest
[__] shows TLC was such cancer DLC is
created it created an entire roster of
super villains from Batman it did Honey
Boo Boo yeah but they're very uh they're
very uh body positive now so you have to
give them that like that's oh yeah
that's a good thing and that is
important it's important to be positive
about people dying and killing
themselves it is no it really is it
really is but okay so I watched this and
this [__] is a because you know
people use a cult for everything now
this is a [__] cult like this was
because I always I kind of always knew
kids that like you know they were kind
they were homeschooled a little weird
and I'm not saying every homeschool
stiff stuff is like this is this
particular sect
of people so okay so break it down what
was this like was did were you were you
in the sense you were like since you
went into school or did you go to normal
school first how did it work out for you
no I was I was homeschooled all the way
through High School my family didn't
join the cult till I was about like 12
years old right uh but yeah I've never
been to a public school never even went
to a private school my first like
experience like in a traditional
educational format was College okay oh
my God that must have been a [__]
shock right oh dude yeah yeah I partied
I partied my dick off I I gotta ask like
do you think that them getting into it
when you were 12 as opposed to them
getting into it when you were like an
infant might have helped a little bit
because maybe you were you were already
when you're 12 you're not obviously
you're not like fully full but you're
already kind of you know gelling as a
human and you've had some experiences do
you think that kind of helped you resist
a little bit of the uh the programming
of it yeah the uh the the brainwashing
yeah I think I think that'll had a lot
to do with it actually because you're
exactly right like you're starting to
already form your own opinions and
Thoughts by the time by the time you're
12 or 13. I don't know when you guys hit
puberty it wasn't you know it still
wasn't for a couple more years but I was
27. this one is nice he's on HRT now
yeah I'm trying to catch up I'm playing
a lot of ketchup seven years that's a
different type of 27 yeah
congratulations yeah
but yeah uh I I think that definitely
helped
um but I mean still man like even at 12
even 13 years old you're still very
impressionable oh of course you know
it's still very much like part of your
formative youth right so I mean I I
definitely when I was before before I
was about 16 I mean I I bought into the
whole mentality with my parents because
you know they told me it was the right
thing to do it seemed pretty cool I mean
we went to these annual conferences and
all these people were were dressed the
same act the same talk the same uh and
so it seemed pretty cool right up until
you get to the point where you're
hitting like the puberty years when you
should start dating all this other stuff
and and then it's kind of like well I
want to go hang out with girls and you
guys are telling me I can't so I don't
like this anymore what was what was
what was the name of the of the cult of
this homeschool cult so it goes by a lot
of different names and that's part of
the confusion of it right so the the
traditional name is Institute and basic
life principles iblp uh their curriculum
that a lot of homeschoolers used was
called the Advanced Training Institute
or ATI they loved they loved acronyms
that was like yeah and the iblp those
are the bodybuilding guys they do the
yeah I think through all the Mr Universe
okay I have IBS it's not that oh okay
and it's it's not the ibf okay it's not
it's like a combination of bodybuilding
and [__] yourself actually a lot of
people don't know that what a painful
existence because you can't wipe because
you're too big
I would have taken it so what you're
saying is it's basically like any squats
over like 200 for me yeah that's it
you're [__] automatic
prolapsed anus so so yeah so I guess it
feels like it's a shell game but I mean
it it almost started by this dude right
the guy I have on screen now what's this
bill okay
he looks like a trustworthy fella dude I
don't have any bad vibes he's still look
at him he's totally on the level this
guy he was so like he he wasn't he was a
very unassuming guy right you would
never look at this guy and be like oh
yeah he's up to some weird stuff well
maybe some weird stuff but not like
shady stuff necessarily
um but yeah I mean he he's not the he's
not like the David koresh type right
like you look at David koresh and you're
like that guy's a maniac
um not this guy so much and I mean he
came to prominence he did these seminars
all over the country right it started in
the 60s into the 70s 80s 90s
um and he was doing these seminars it's
like the estimate is that I think it's
over 3 million people attended his
seminars over the course of the years I
mean the guy was prolific
um and his message was all about uh how
to raise Godly families like that's that
was his bread and butter right right
never mind the fact that the dude was
never married never had kids supposedly
never even in his words kissed a girl
ever in his life oh that's strange it's
weird that he released a public
statement there was and and I'm sure
we're gonna get into it he released a
public statement after some scandals
that he went through that said uh
literally I've never kissed a girl he
didn't say woman he said girl which is
just creepy and that you know what
connect can I jump on that I want to
point out you know because we both do we
do a bunch of shows and like we do other
shows too we're like I'm sure like when
we watch videos and you like watch a
little and that's always been a thing
for me when we watch like breakdown
videos yeah it's a big red flag when
somebody's like girls and you're like
you're 40. you're 40. I like bomb tits
bro what about MILFs now bro get the
[__] out of here girls roll yeah that's
just creepy it's very sus you know it is
it's why so so I I it's so creepy it's
almost like like in the Catholic church
when you go to a priest who's like a
closeted gay guy that the family sent
off to be a priest so he had a vow of
celibacy and they never have families
and they're like go talk to you go talk
to your priest about your marriage
marriage counseling so he doesn't even
know what he's talking about so a couple
a couple people in the chat are asking
what the denomination was this uh so
that's the interesting thing about this
cult it wasn't it wasn't relegated to a
specific denomination of Christianity
they didn't mess with the church okay at
all like the churches were still
independent a lot of the cult members
did home Church in fact my family did
home church for a little while with a
couple other families because I guess we
just weren't isolated enough it was like
you know let's pull out a church and
let's just do this with others we don't
want to go outside yeah exactly exactly
yeah we don't want to expose you to
anything right so um it never really was
a denomination but I will say it has its
it's basis in the fundamental Baptist
Church okay the most like Southern like
Southern Baptist borderline snake biting
even worse man like yeah yeah borderline
snakes yeah snake stuff was right the
snake handling guy I know this I know
this world a little bit like I I won't
say I grew up in a cult but I grew up in
that very Evangelical yeah like speaking
in tonguese Jesse Duplantis getting a
prophecy started the guy with the
sunglasses yeah always yeah and I don't
know my mom ended up dying poor with
cancer and all those guys got private
jets so I don't know I don't really buy
it I know I know but I under like I
can't even pretend like I would
understand your world but like getting
even just a diet taste of it in life
like we weren't like totally shut off
but a lot of our stuff was well let's go
hang out with the church people and
let's kind of you know let's always go
there and then boom ninth grade I went
to public school and I was like whoa
there's a lot of cool stuff out here
that I've been missing yeah yeah girls
are making out with me this real I I
went I I went I went so similarly I
didn't okay nothing close but I did go
to this school for like a middle school
and it was called Miami Lakes Christian
Academy and it was weird because they
had this PACE program right where they
didn't teach you stuff you get these
booklets right and you go through these
booklets and then you would teach
yourself and at the end you would take a
test and then the teacher would just
check your test but like you could go at
your own pace and it was super weird
because it had these really creepy like
Christian cartoons that were like really
like [__] just like about your like
sexuality but it's like supposed to be a
comic strip it was [__] super weird
stuff but and then again then I went and
then High School I ended up going to to
public school and I'm like what the [__]
is this and I was stupid because I I
learn anything
well everything is new they weren't
checking and I'd [__] Wing the test
why would I even try
yeah that that's that's the interesting
thing about the the education that I got
so my parents were very adamant about
you know academic learning right like
they were real serious about it probably
like that Christian Middle School was
right
um and so I got a phenomenal I I tested
out of college like when I finally went
to college uh I I tested out of the
first three years I didn't have to go to
class for the first three years of
college I was able to you know just uh
take these standardized tests right uh
but a lot of other homeschoolers got
just the most dog [__] education you've
ever seen like all they learned about
was the Bible their entire education was
based on Parables of Jesus it's just I
mean it was insane oh so you've got like
these two extremes so something else
that I I noticed about this it seems to
me watching this that it wasn't just a
cult in a traditional sense but it was
also a Ponzi scheme in the way that
there was a business built around it
where they they were they were they were
telling you guys or telling the people
like don't watch any TV and if you have
a TV it could only have a vcr and the
only programs you can watch are these
pre by this guy and some other pre-made
videotapes instructional video tapes
that they would sell to you I'm like wow
that's like [__] next level
but it was all in God's name so it was
cool right it was yeah that that and it
totally was it was this giant Ponzi
scheme like the most spiritual uh
multi-level marketing program you've
ever seen because because yeah I mean we
this this was a crazy so they had they
had compounds all over the world
um uh they probably had at the height
they probably had anywhere from 50 to 60
compounds
um here in the states they had them in
Australia Russia New Zealand Mexico
Ecuador uh I mean just everywhere dude
um and and one of the things was if you
if you wanted to advance your spiritual
life you could go and minister at one of
the compounds which minister was just
code for work your ass off and not only
were you working for free but a lot of
times your parents were paying the cult
to send you off to these compounds for
this Advanced Training uh which is just
bananas
um I went to
um uh the training center in
Indianapolis Indiana which is one of the
most the most notorious training centers
my parents sent me there for a
rehabilitation program I don't know how
many thousands of dollars they paid for
this thing but I I literally just did uh
man hard manual labor the entire time I
was there and uh at one point even got
locked in solitary confinement for a
week Jesus wait they had so they had
like a sea org yeah that's like
Scientology [__] yeah you mean locked in
like solitary how old were you 16. 16.
how long are you in solitary confinement
for a little over a week
it was intense man it was in one of my
buddies was locked up in there for over
a month and he was what are you doing
there what did it let you do in there
like what did you do read a Bible uh
that's that's you got one meal a day you
had a Bible and a bed and that was it
like like well and you had a shower too
you had a you had a shower also uh holy
[__] dude I mean that that's all you had
yeah it was it was insane I mean I I I
don't I blocked a lot of it out
um but I just remember after the first
probably between 24 and 48 Hours
um I started like questioning myself
where I was what was real what wasn't
like this psychosis started to set in uh
because you didn't talk to anyone they
would drop your meal off shut the door
again and you were just there locked in
a room well yeah they've already found
like that that's literally cruel and
unusual punishment even for like the
worst prisoners in America like they've
said that you can't just like even
nowadays are doing studies they're like
look I know this guy's like a [__]
horrible felon or whatever but you can't
just stick them in a [__] room for
them like he's gonna be worse when he
gets out they don't get better you know
even in prison they at least let you out
like if you're in solitary confinement
in prison they let you out of yourself
for typically an hour at a time right
right and the rest of the time you're
just in the hole
um we didn't even get let out for
well we're gonna get let it let out at
all uh and the only human contact we had
is when they dropped off our meals
damn dude that's like that's like
[__] Arkham Jesus Christ Batman
villain like they're [__] locking you
up by your Joker or some [__] dude I've
been on a villain Arc for like 20 years
now it's great yeah no one complained me
dude that [__] is I I will say this I I
would just make a small recommendation
villain ark's fine but you're gonna
eventually as you get older you're not
gonna be as angry you're going to want
to do the anti-hero arc that's that's
the final that's the final evolution
that's the anti-hero I've settled very
comfortably into that role and it's very
nice because you can do good [__] at the
right times but at the same time nobody
expects anything of you you know that's
perfect perfect
I wanted to ask actually speaking of
that because I don't want to keep acting
like I'm distracted here I've been
looking for your twitters what am I
trying to do oh you do have I wanna plug
it because I wanna yeah I got it yeah no
no
the video started playing on his phone
you know you know it's Davey Jacks it's
uh at Davey Jacks at davejax uh at the a
v e y j a x correct okay that's right
yeah got it you got it and that's pretty
much what it is on everything uh just
the d-a-v-e-y yeah we just wanted to
make sure that people I'm sure all the
women want to follow you now because I'm
seeing those comments Jesus
Culture the new serial killers oh yes it
is crazy yes it's crazy and and I I
started doing this podcast series about
the cult not even for like the notoriety
but just because I knew there were other
people that have been through what I you
know they went through what I went
through uh and they're still battling
this trauma right I I purged all the
trauma with with drugs eventually Amen
brother Amen brother you know uh but
yeah I uh I just wanted I just know I
just followed them I just want to say
look just just be do me a favor since
you're on our show don't be like Jake
Shields or raw egg Nationalist and not
follow me back all right that's a little
oh oh that's weird rock Nationalist and
Jake Shields followed me back so it's
I'm fine don't worry I'm cool that's
cool I'm a cool guy what's the
sunglasses I I swear to you that's how I
got this scar man was wearing sunglasses
in side during the day and I got punched
in the face for it yeah really
wait like in the Cults are just out in
the world no this is out in the world
dude wow this was out in the normal
world that makes people really angry
when I was wearing sunglasses and you
can't [__] with them because as you've
seen he's been institutionalized so he
like yeah you can't hurt me bro I grew
up in a cult
so how was your childhood I grew up in a
cult but now like you said that'll get
you laid to be like really tell me
everything about it [__] chicks that
look like Allison Mack walking up to you
all the time now these Nexium people
what was it like tell me what it was so
brave
I'm not gonna lie though I [__] the [__]
out of Allison Mack I thought you were
gonna talk about me holy [__]
I want to say man Allison Mack bro you
know she's wild you know you know she
does you know she does she's out here
Brandon [__] anybody get branded in
your uh in your neck of the woods
uh not that I'm aware just emotionally
branded not like if it's a clean brand
like I'm all [__] up in here yeah just
permanently scarred on the inside that's
all yeah yeah I can't [__] so I was I
was I was watching it too the other
thing I thought was like what was like
did you date what was dating like
because I saw like the clothing was like
bloomers and [__] like it was really
like very medieval like [__] oh yeah no
I I didn't I wasn't allowed to date at
all that's actually why I got sent to
the Indianapolis training centers
because when I was 16 I started dating a
girl from my church
um who was not part of the cult she was
actually the head cheerleader at her
High School of course of course this
guy's a look at this [__] handsome
dude obviously this guy's in a [__]
must be a caged animal all the broads
want him even more because he's not
supposed to be with him yeah oh that's a
good I didn't I never even thought think
about it it was exactly what it was she
knew that forbidden fruits off limits
right oh man all these all these all
these [__] still have even them bro
all these [__] have even though women
women just want to corrupt things yeah
you know what I mean it's so they're
like oh okay I can ruin this kid's life
this is awesome I mean that that
certainly I'm sure that had a part to
play women everyone loves trauma right
yeah of course everyone loves drama well
I I should say mentally Disturbed people
like myself and y'all we love children
it's the best attracted to it it makes
sense it's comfortable for us so yeah I
mean that's certainly played a part uh
but yeah so we we started dating and and
when my parents found out I mean it was
it I mean it was it was all over right
what happened like did what did they say
they tell you you're not allowed because
she's not in the same cult or they they
moved they moved my family halfway
across country wait a second so you're
telling me
such a cocksmith that they had to
[__] relocate your family like you
were in witness protection Jesus that's
basically what it was yeah yeah finger
bang one cheerleader and your dad has to
get a new job like this is complicated
why were you relocating my sunky [__]
cheerleaders he won't stop and you're
like I don't know why doesn't he just
stay what is it like a [__] child
support thing or whatever these Church
girls alone it's crazy they're [__]
wild what I don't understand is right if
I had a son who was just such a [__]
he was just swinging dick like this I'd
go look I'm gonna look at the way Jewish
and Arab people do it with their
daughters right look if you're
attracting these hoes bring them into
the thing we need businesses a honey pot
honestly this is what I already
introduced you all the time they're like
you should be exactly dude if you're
like a really successful like you know a
Jewish guy will come and go you should
meet my daughter same thing with Arabs
you should meet my daughter they have a
hot one they're like hey you should meet
her they want to pull you in they yeah
bro this is [__] wild today so so you
were dating somebody and I mean I think
you are allowed up to date but only if
it's like approved by your family is
that correct okay so it's more courting
right methodology is uh courtship yeah
according yeah according yeah exactly
which which is essentially just uh a
fancy way to say arranged marriage right
um it's it's the Evangelical world's
version of arranged marriage right uh
and so yeah you're exactly right uh
basically both families have to approve
of the relationship the intent when you
start courting a woman is marriage like
that's it you're not you're not courting
for fun you're not going out on cute
little dates no this is a serious matter
both families are involved you're never
left alone with your I don't even know
what to it's not a girl Prospect I guess
here here they give they give you all
the fruit they give you a book of paint
swatches and you get to pick one out
like it's Pokemon cards I'll take that
one you're like listen this is just the
training camp all right it's just spring
we got a long way to listen season and
most of you aren't going to be here by
the end of this
that's the other crazy thing is that in
this cult like the it was normal for
women to get married around like 18 19
years old like that was very standard
okay which which is just crazy because
that's a child bride right right
we're right on the edge and and but it's
not even the edge part though but it's
also like I I saw in in the documentary
that the point was to literally never
stop having kids have as many [__]
kids as you can as you can no matter
what
um and and and that that's the other
thing so they wanted him to start young
because that's how you could pump those
numbers 19 out you have to you have to
start young and it's just and what was
like that weird like military school for
do what was that that was super creepy
oh you guys had your airplane
team Airline okay sorry can you say that
what I get what's it called air land
emergency resource team okay AKA alert
because once again you know the acronyms
right
um and it was basically homeschool
Special Forces that's what it was uh
Christian boot camp for homeschool
Special Forces so you guys had your own
like FedEx holy [__] I found yeah
oh yeah no here so here it is I found I
found it I found I found from four years
ago uh a recruit I guess a recruitment
bit or whatever this right am I correct
yep that's it uh-huh dude that's one of
their recruiting videos to be there for
their families for the Long Haul well
this is for a young men who say I want
more I'm not content with where I'm at
we're all called to lead in some
capacity and we need to be ready and
equipped and prepared to do so alert to
me is all about discipleship
basic training okay hold on this is very
middle but what what what did you do I
would have no problem with this if it
was like a voluntary like local
community and you had like your young
sons getting together and you have a lot
of community I'd be like oh this is
pretty cool but it's like oh no this is
for cult though this guy was trying to
make his own boy Army this is a world
domination play okay can I say though
can I say though they're making much
better military uh recruitment
commercials than the American Military
is nowadays so I'll give them that much
better marketing stuff is next level
yeah like the videography in it well the
one here's the one good thing is unlike
the US military you're not going to see
any trans soldiers well that's what I
was getting but that's what I was
getting at I was like you guys actually
have a better looking commercial than
our current military because nowadays
it's like I'm a woman with a dick and
I'm represented in the Air Force and
you're like we're so [__] and I
started and I also noticed that they put
a black guy in this because I was
something else in the documentary they
were the little not that accepting at
the beginning of the cult of homeschool
black kids it was super weird man this
[__] was wild so I actually went when I
went to rehab there was a uh a black guy
uh that was in the same Rehabilitation
oh [__] me here's the worst part about
it
um he was special needs like severely
special needs so they sent this poor
dude his family sent him up to this
intense program where he was just gonna
work his ass off and the guy can I I
mean he was verbal but not really but
you could tell he was definitely not all
there yeah
a hundred thousand percent
so so yeah I mean maybe I don't know
dude I I never really saw the the racism
side of things in the cult but I I for
sure know it existed and it was death
like there were definitely like white
National undertones for sure it it's
it's we it's very odd like you know a
military and and when you said world
domination you that they they say that
in the documentary you're not joking
that is the ultimate goal of this group
is to keep reproducing faster than
anybody else and basically take over you
know yeah flood the market they're
putting people in politics I saw that
too like you know running for local
politics well I mean why not I mean if
the Chinese can [__] do it in the
Indians and the goddamn Muslims why
can't we do it so this is the alert do
you now does every dude in this have to
do this or no so I I actually I I never
went through the alert basic uh basic
training right by the time I would have
been eligible for that I was already in
trouble with the Institute as as we call
it with the cult I was already in
trouble I'd already had a I had a
meeting with a personal meeting with
Bill Gothard when I got in trouble in
rehab after I got out of solitary
confinement
um he had a a conversation with me and
essentially the options were you're
either out of here or we send you to an
even more intensive program where they
basically send you into the woods for a
log cabin program where you just hang
out in isolation with one Mentor until
you basically Shape Up
um so I was already in trouble I wasn't
going to be allowed in alert
um so so I never went through that but
the majority of the people that I talked
to that I talked to that went through
this program uh talk about how insane it
was
um very little attention was paid to you
know like physical health guys were
getting injured they would just tell
them to keep going and if they didn't
they they just didn't love God enough
essentially I mean it was it was intense
but the the the hilarious thing about it
is these guys are Marching around in
these crisp Snappy uniforms making
homeschool homeschool girls wet right
um they never trained with uh any
weapons there was no hand-to-hand combat
uh training at all so so basically they
were just getting deployed around the
world to help with humanitarian missions
very much so or like or like or like
Mormons Maybe
no not even not even that I mean it was
disaster relief that they were so they
helped out with Hurricane Katrina okay
there was an F5 tornado that blew
through uh Oklahoma City they helped
with with that actually
when the Oklahoma City Federal Building
the whole Timothy McVeigh situation yeah
supposedly they were some of the first
guys on the scene there uh yeah they
were there the day before
they dropped off all the fertilizers
wow you guys were there really early huh
yeah we wanted to help
we got a tip something I I don't know
so they were their first at Waco too did
you know that it's super weird always
the first on the scene to help
any anywhere there's a disaster they
just somehow show up but uh the
interesting thing was that uh Bill
Gothard the cult leader he would he
would essentially a lot of times use
alert use these guys as a bargaining
chip especially with foreign countries
where local governments basically saying
hey if you help us out we're going to
send in our guys to help you clean up
whatever you need cleaned up right and
not like not like fixers uh but like in
the literal sense like if you've got a
building that needs to be rehabbed or
demolished or go through the work we'll
just send our guys in here Free Labor
baby yeah okay so it feel man it's it's
so weird hearing that this is like still
happening now that this is like this is
[__] like weird it's like it's like
the Scientology stuff except until this
documentary came out nobody was nobody
was talking about this deal I mean I
knew tangentially of stuff because of
the news coverage or the Duggar stuff
because I mean obviously that was like
that must be like that family must be a
patron saint for that group because it's
a it was a public face right absolutely
yes yeah 100 and and it it feels it
feels like that was just like look it's
a like I in the documentary they say
that Duggar's like how can you be on a
TV show when you don't believe in TV and
it's like well it's okay if it's for
Ministry or whatever and it was yeah it
was their evangelism it was they
considered it part of the ministry even
though those of us in the Cults weren't
allowed to watch it because it was on
you know that's hilarious so so they
weren't even allowed to watch it it was
just a propaganda for other people and
then of course for those who don't know
his son was like caught like molesting
family members and child porn about the
Duggar kid yeah yeah Josh Duggar yeah
yeah that was awful and and it was it
came out that TLC was like kind of
running interference
no let's not shut up not even not even
running interference even after it
happened that show you what a cash cow
this family was they were trying to do
spin-offs with uh the other kids because
they didn't want the dad in it because
you know the whole it was a little but
they were like they were still really
trying really hard yeah going back to my
point about like outside of just the
cult and the Duggars but like TLC became
like this Factory of monsters yeah and
like everybody they created would get so
[__] high on themselves that their
lives would get really [__] they'd
always be a scandal and then they would
always be spin-offs Hogan same thing you
had [__] Hogan knows best and then
everything fell apart like the mom was
[__] the daughter's friend and Nick
killed the guy or caved his head in with
a car and it got crazy and then they
were like well we'll do spin-off broke a
music career like because we're still
getting a number of TLC should have
never how did it go from like oh man hey
polar bears you know come out you know
eight months out of the Year unlike
their cousin the black bear like that
usually used to be and then it's each
and then they have a show called Best
Funeral Ever yeah and then it just came
out with like you know incest is best
season three and you're like what is
happening
what am I watching uh is that an actual
show cause I would love to I think yeah
the dogger thing
um I thought that was one of the
spin-offs yeah can I ask um because we
since we're we're so bad at doing shows
uh with guests we're terrible and we
always just end up hanging out with them
and having fun that's always what
happened do anything like we never do
anything professional uh I do want to
point out again it's Davey jacks on
Twitter and you also do stand up are you
where are you based out of I want to I'm
trying to yeah
coming out you have a special coming out
right yeah yeah I do uh so I'm based in
San Antonio Texas oh nice uh I'm a Texan
boy for Life uh we go up there every
once in a while yeah so we're still
trying to secede at some point it's
going to happen uh but yeah so San
Antonio Texas I do have that special
coming up I'm uh that should be dropping
uh middle part of August as a matter of
fact we're still we're still working on
putting everything together uh but it's
gonna be all about like the entire
special is gonna be about uh how I grew
up in this cult and [__] yeah dude
trauma into uh into comedy that that
dude that [__] is that [__] is like is
there a name for you where people should
look out for or is it just still we're
still yeah when it drops it's gonna be
uh the cult kid oh okay okay I want
people to follow this because yeah I've
had fun so far these people yeah he's
[__] great yeah I know I mean yeah
yeah uh so this is this is it
it is so so then leaving it right did
yeah did it take you like were you were
your was your family like let's say the
heart the TV stuff right was your family
like hard-nosed about you not watching
TV did you really not like or did you
sneak TV and watch it anyway like it
just feels like I wonder if it's like
you know being Amish and like using a
phone for the first time you know when
you left what was it like so so so
that's actually there's a funny so I
haven't I haven't told this on on any of
the podcasts or anything that I've done
but my family had like this little nine
inch garage TV you know what you know
what I'm talking about yeah like those
little TVs that uh you can put on the
garage count or whatever and watch
sports while you're working out in the
garage yeah my dad had a little one of
those oh like a little ones yeah okay
yeah exactly yeah so they had one of
those and um when I was 14 years old I I
would wait on the weekends I would wait
until you know I had some alone time
like my parents were off doing something
and and I could commandeer this little
garage TV and I would watch the Spanish
this channel because they had a show on
Saturdays called muy caliente oh you're
speaking Royce's language yeah yes they
did
yes Caliente that was my sexual
Revolution
I have been obsessed with Latin women
ever since oh yo Hey listen Amen brother
not even just because of that but
because of you know where I was raised
and exposure to yeah brother I'm with
you and honestly statistically it's your
best bet it really is if you're looking
to settle down in the future these
[__] Western white women are all
[__] in the head yeah these cartel
wives never flip bro they're like I
didn't see anything [__] it I didn't see
[__] dude get you a breath get you a
brown Catholic Latino who's just
Catholic enough that your family stays
intact but not so Catholic that you guys
end up you know moving around a lot
again with the kids and you know you
know making them doing their outfits I'm
stabbed I I will I will go ahead and
like that's why I said that's why I said
to be honest this is why I said when
you're ready to settle down when you're
ready to settle down that's right and
yeah
Puerto Ricans I would not recommend them
no that that's a very aggressive because
they'll stab you even if you don't
choose those Puerto Ricans
extra spicy they didn't say they're not
hot I didn't say they're not hot what I
said was they're [__] insane and
that's all I'm saying that's all I'm
saying just be very careful okay I plead
the fifth because I've dated a Puerto
Rican yeah I mean everyone want this to
get back to her because you don't want
to get stabbed
oh [__] yeah man it's so so so so so so
you were sneaking TV and stuff like that
um and obviously you you were you were
dating behind their back you know so it
did seem like you you had a couple more
chances to escape a couple more chances
to do that because it seemed like some
of these P at least from what I saw in
this document the Duggars are a great
example because the reason I bring them
up the most because that's the family
that has the most film on them and like
seeing their daily lives and it always
seemed like talk about them like their
running backs well here's why
we have a lot of Life on these people
these people study you know
running backs or maybe kickers they're
all white
um
certainly not a corner yeah
harder dunkers is what I call them so
um
anyway
uh it seemed like the only way to
describe like all the kids in that
family they feel like they were all
Chick-fil-A employees they were all too
nice like I'm not saying like in a bat
I'm saying like you know when somebody
when something is so nice it seems
artificial yeah yep you know it's
[__] Max Payne music playing behind
those eyes yeah I know what's going on
yeah exactly exactly was there a lot of
that were you were were were you told
that you had to have this front facing
positivity yes absolutely and and women
the way that Michelle Duggar the mom the
way that she talked this like really
high breathy voice
um that's how a lot of the women in the
cult talk because having that you know
that that quiet modest sweet voice was
considered more Godly right because that
showed you were a submissive woman uh
that you respected your male authorities
and so it was it was a lot of that kind
of stuff and and that's why I loved it I
learned when her mercy was a
Mercy right and the callings everyone
had their own little yeah character
quality character quality so yeah they
have these character qualities and turns
out all the women were Mercy where they
had the burden stuff and all the and all
the guys were teachers where they had to
teach stuff it was wild it's such a
turn-off for me I don't I don't want a
mousy chick who doesn't say [__] with a
chest out like you know what I mean I
want a raspy cigarette voice Hispanic
women again
black women Jewish women I've dated some
very overbearing women I want you to
[__] yeah I don't want to sit here
did you wanna yeah Mercer stick is the
opposite of John Mayer's yeah
dude this dude gets tied up
my dick is the U.N yeah yeah
Mercer's driven to a lot of
check-cashing places
um so
yeah no baby I'll wait in the car
um so yeah right I've mostly [__]
strippers for years they don't check
cash checks [__] are you talking about
shout out yeah baby hey he goes to the
check cashing place I go to the
methadone clinic that's where I you know
yeah hey baby look I know you're nodding
off now but here's my card oh yeah when
you wake up you'll remember me here let
me take it okay that's that's the thing
about that's the thing about [__] in
a methadone clinic they all want to go
for a cup of coffee
because they're all they're like oh I'm
so tired yeah I love a cup of coffee
right now yo come on they're drinking
two red bulls always itches for some
reason they're [__] pounding Red
Bulls on the way to the coffee place
yeah I know I know
but all right sorry this is that's the
problem with this show such a great you
have such great stories you're funny
you're funny so we just goof around yeah
you're welcome to come back on whenever
you know I have a feeling you got a
YouTube too right I just I looked that
up yes I subbed to that as well yeah
yeah I just uh I think it's I don't even
know what my YouTube handle is actually
I was on another bus well I found it
informed me if people Google uh like the
actual title of that uh docu Series in
your name David Jackson they'll find it
oh yeah it comes up yeah it does you
know it's it's funny because I'm I'm
this is going to be another situa as I
call another Ryan long situation Ryan
Long's our friend we love Ryan long but
we had him on right before you're gonna
blow up I already know oh yeah we have
we have good you're absolutely good news
for you right we actually do have a
curse on this show where everybody this
is true this is true the minute we make
friends with somebody and they come on
the show and we have chemistry they go
on to [__] immediately blow up Alex
Stein's another great example and then
usually well that's my boy
another uh you know sponsor or another
uh platform Harrison Smith Harrison
Smith's another one I hate them all they
all come on you're gonna blow up and
then you then later on when you come
back down you'll be like hey can I come
back on and like plug this nft that I'm
working on or something that's usually
what happens or something like that well
actually because of my cult upbringing
when I form a circle of people
I stick with them dude thick or thin bro
I'm coming back listen he shows up but
he shows up and all of a sudden he's
[__] has the same haircut as you the
next day
same shirt you're like what are you
doing no it's kind of just something I
have a certain thing
it just makes me comfortable so he's
self-soothing behaviors he comes on he's
like so what are we doing today and
every time every time you go what's up
man he goes like this ah oh I saw that
dude they were they had a video that
shows you how to beat your kids that's
[__] insane yes that was uh well it's
Michael Pearl Michael Pearl yeah Pearl
yes I'm gonna play devil's advocate here
because I told Roy Sofia right I
understand that that sounds bad like
when you hear it said that way but do
you want people that are untrained just
beating their kids all willy-nilly
or would you rather them have a little
you know valid point yeah it was it's
just like the coat hanger on the leg for
me you know it's crazy what these guys
were doing yeah I mean it was it was
like torture like the stuff they were
doing could be classified as legitimate
torture uh the way that they were
disciplining their kids insane it was
called train uh train up a child uh yeah
yeah it's it's the it's these guys dude
I saw like a by the way I'm in a rabbit
hole now because of you thank you by the
way and this is all I I now like I'm I'm
into this [__] cold [__] now it's uh
it's uh this guy right that guy that
would be Michael Pearl that guy's
definitely said the n-word
yeah
when I say say it I mean felt it
to go back to your earlier point he said
that with his chest with his chest with
all of his soul look at him of course he
did he said it like Gandalf on that
bridge you know what I mean yeah man it
was like videos of him like him hitting
like a doll with a stick and the right
way to hit that like this is like again
it is super [__] weird to me that
this is still going on in 2023 like this
feels like old tiny [__] but like
there's a lot of these things for the
next few months another good example but
like Scientology is still [__] going
on but I mean honestly I think in a lot
of ways this is worse than Scientology
for one big reason because this is the
kids man like you're you know many
Scientology usually get them in don't
get me wrong there's some people that
are born into Scientology but it's not
really that many if you really look at
it it's usually people that convert
because it's a cool thing this is just
being born into a [__] cult that
you're into forever and you're ashamed
to for into Reverend and then just
perpetuating it and by the time you're
in it if you're if you're at 18 and
you're having kids at that point you're
already stuck because I already have
kids and we have I'm not going to leave
now because you know then it really is
like in a weird Ponzi scheme and all
this stuff and it's like I was seeing
some of the books is this like
homeschooling like people think like oh
I'm gonna teach you some of the books
like wisdom books what were those who
are just oh yeah what were these wisdom
books yeah so so that was the that was
the ATI part of iblp the Advanced
Training Institute you had these wisdom
booklets and the wisdom booklets were
basically positioned as a homeschool
curriculum that you know you just repeat
every year you go through the wisdom
booklets once a year right there's 54 of
them or something like that it's based
on the cert the whole thing is based on
The Sermon on the Mount uh Jesus is
Sermon on the Mount right um like
Matthew 5.
um and so you go through these wisdom
booklets uh for your education and
supposedly by the time you graduate high
school you have graduated with a college
degree equivalent which is absolute bull
I mean you barely learned fractions in
these wisdom booklets and it was all
based on biblical principles The
Parables of Jesus it was which there's
nothing wrong with the Bible there's
nothing wrong with Jesus there's nothing
wrong with it but trying to Center an
education especially like a high school
education around Bible verses is [__]
nuts it is weird because there's no mat
it's true and it's the only thing I know
is how many how many cubics there was to
build the uh the ark which is another
thing they said fossils were but fossils
were put there the dinosaur fossils were
there after the flood like they weren't
like that yeah that's another thing
about these people and by the way
speaking of fractions it looks like the
only fraction that micropro knows is
three-fifths and that's it Jesus Zen
Rhino Zen Rhino says locals is now on
Roku you can watch your subscribe
content using locals TV thank you for
Zen right now that's actually pretty
cool to know
um yeah man imrano's great he actually
super chatted and then just did a live
read we should have done thank you I
know we appreciate it we're actually
very appreciated we had like three
Thirty 800 people watching today which
was great live it's [__] awesome so
thank you everybody hit the like button
but why this is terrible we have such a
great guest and all we do is fart around
I thought this was good though yeah I
mean for us I guess it's been fun yeah I
had a I had a I had a good time well I
mean we're gonna get him followers yeah
we're gonna we got to clip this
interview because this is one of the
best interviews we've done no I will
agree with this this was we can um yeah
but no this is what we do on our show
and like so many women have fallen in
love with them in the chat it's getting
weird I don't like yeah Davey I don't
know if you're ever like familiar with
like uh Opie and Anthony back in the day
or uh yeah of course so they started up
in New England when I lived up there
yeah I'm from New York so that's yeah
like we kind of have a similar thing
with guests where it's like you know if
we had a studio and you were coming in
for a Morning Show it'd be the same
thing we're like yeah we're just gonna
go live and [__] around like yeah just
hang out and some people think and some
people swim you know yeah next time next
time you come it's going to go through
our regular show and watch videos
that'll be fun uh but I would love to
tell you also after about like after I
got out of the cult because I went
through this crazy uh like addiction
process that was into like I was doing
everything well yeah because guys will
love it because because I'm sure like
it's it's one of those like you know if
you've never had cake and you have cake
for the first time all you wanted [__]
cake yeah I want to eat the cake I want
to jit on the cake I wanna I wanna I
wanna snort the cake I want to [__] the
cake I want to do everything with the
cake a woman in the chat just says I can
fix him oh that's great oh good this is
[__] great yeah keep having back on
top we'll talk drugs
hey you know what let's have you on like
very soon I mean seriously come back on
because no this is a lot of fun I did
not realize how much we were gonna how
much we're gonna get out of it this has
been great uh Davey jacks j-a-x on
Twitter and uh like I said I don't have
the link because we got a new I got it I
do have it I will pop the link for his
YouTube I gotcha for his YouTube as well
um I got you and then I'll get logged
into all this [__] tomorrow yeah dude
this is uh this was this was a lot of
fun man I just realized an hour it's an
hour already [__] flew by that that
was that was [__] great uh dude you
come we're gonna get you on again like
maybe even the same month because I do
now we I want to actually go more into
this because first off this shit's
[__] fascinating and everybody in the
chat seemed to [__] love this because
this [__] is this is wild [__] like it's
something you don't think is happening
and when you go wow like this is a dude
younger than me who just this is
happening now is is [__] crazy to me
that people are still listening to like
Michael Pearl's teachings it's [__]
odd there's a brand new generation of it
too dude there's like there's there's
legitimate jinsiers uh that are coming
up this way I saw the tick tock
ERS I know Nick Fuentes no that's a
different guy uh no The Tick Tock The
Tick Tock he's the one that's uh with
the fresh and fit guy Nick Fuentes
um The Tick Tock yeah sneako ever no
it's a different guy uh the tape
Brothers Watcher uh we don't speak
politics bottled water bottled water um
anyway uh another thing is they'll go
out there and I'll dominate somebody I
don't [__] him right in his ass and
he'll be the gay one come on top G baby
let's go oh gee I'm not bottom G
[Laughter]
because I'm selfish they accuse me of
doing the lover boy method to [__] guys
all right you don't [__] my ass my ass
[__] you dominance
oh my God it's so stupid thank you for
being on bro this is a lot of fun man
this is a [__] great time uh I'll
shoot you another message right
afterwards we'll set up the next
interview ASAP because this was this is
this was [__] great and I definitely
want to hear about you leaving that [__]
dude that this is this is this is why I
like the documentary don't get me wrong
but this is way more fun because the
documentary is a little more sanitized
you're just like no I'm gonna [__]
tell you about my [__] crazy life
it's [__] North then [__] get into
it you were [__] a cocksmith they put
you in stock so you can find me because
you [__] too much that's [__] insane
that is pretty cool oh yeah no and and
uh one of the incidents was with uh one
of well two of the women at the training
center yeah that's why I ultimately got
sent to Solitaire wait wait
yeah
that's a perfect teaser thank you so
much for being on man we really [__]
appreciate it dude this was this was a a
goddamn blast uh take it easy man see
you later we'll see you oh see you man
uh go check them out that was that was
that was [__] great everyone knows
how I feel about new guests no he's
amazing it's literally always a roll of
the dice and I'm always like fine we'll
do we'll try it and uh and then see
anytime somebody's good I'm pleasantly
surprised I'm like oh I Ruled okay thank
God he's [__] great thank you pink
trip for hooking us up man although yeah
that was pink true that was shout out to
Pink trip so thank you so much pink
subscribe to Pink trip too that's on
YouTube right uh yeah I've never heard
of it I'm yeah that's right you're
welcome pink trip you're gonna get the
Revenge of this bump